Hello, I'm Daven Hiskey, you're watching the
TodayIFoundOut YouTube channel.
In the video today, we're looking at that
time drilling an 14 inch hole accidentally
created a 1,300 foot deep saltwater lake out
of a formerly 10-foot deep freshwater one.
Lake Peigneur is located in Louisiana near
the Gulf of Mexico.
Before 1980, it was an approximately 10-foot
deep fresh water lake with an island in the
middle.
Next to it, and partially under it, Diamond
Crystal Salt Company maintained a salt mine,
with salt being mined near the lake since
1919.
Around large underground salt domes, you can
often find oil.
As explained by one Dr. Whitney J. Autin,
"...salt moves upwards and it pierces through
surrounding strata... and this piercing produces
faults and folds within the surrounding sediments
producing an ideal mechanism to trap oil."
As such, Texaco was doing some drilling in
the lake.
On November 20, 1980, crews on the oil rig
in the lake ran into a problem.
At just over 1,200 feet, their drill seized
up.
Not a major problem normally, they worked
to get it loose.
In the process, they heard several loud pops
then the oil rig tilted like it was going
to collapse.
The men got off the rig and to shore as quickly
as possible.
Not a moment too soon.
Just 19 minutes after their drill had seized
up, they watched from the shore as the 150
foot tall platform overturned and sunk into
the 10 foot lake...
Next, the astounded drillers watched as a
whirlpool slowly formed, soon reaching a quarter
mile wide and centered over the site of the
oil drilling.
Whoopsadoodle.
At the same time the oil workers were watching
their $5 million drilling rig disappear into
the lake, workers in the salt mines below
the lake noticed something was wrong as well;
a stream of water was found flowing along
the floor of the mine shaft at about the 1,300
foot level of the mine, which went down to
about 1,500 feet at its deepest.
As water wasn't supposed to be in the mine,
the evacuation alarm was raised.
Foreman Randy LaSalle then drove a cart around
to the regions of the mine where the alarm
signal could not be seen, making sure everyone
knew about the evacuation.
By the time those from the deepest areas of
the mine made it to the elevator, they encountered
knee-deep water.
Despite the fact that the mine was rapidly
filling with water and the exit elevator could
only take up eight people at a time, all 55
miners were evacuated successfully.
It wasn't clear to the miners what had happened
at the time, but from the evidence at hand,
the theory is that the drilling crew miscalculated
their location and instead of being several
hundred feet from the salt mine, they had
instead been directly over a portion of it
and penetrated the salt dome.
The initial hole resulting from this mistake
was only 14 inches wide, but water spraying
in at extremely high pressure quickly widened
the hole.
The water also dissolved the salt pillars
that supported the ceiling of the mine, causing
the shafts to collapse.
The widening of the hole and the collapse
of the mine gave strength to the whirlpool
on the surface of the lake, which caused major
damage.
Docks, another drilling platform, a 70 acre
island in the middle of the lake, eleven barges,
vehicles, trees and a parking lot near the
lake were all sucked into the mine below.
The pull of the whirlpool was so strong that
it reversed the flow of the 12-mile-long Delcambre
Canal that drained the lake into the Gulf
of Mexico.
Three hours after the first signs of trouble,
the three to four billion gallons of water
that had made up the lake were almost all
gone, having dropped into the mine below,
leaving a gaping crater.
The backward-flowing canal formed a 160 foot
waterfall that gradually refilled the lake,
this time with salt water from the Gulf.
The 10-foot deep freshwater lake was now a
saltwater one, now approximately 1,300 feet-deep.
Amazingly, there were no human deaths or serious
injuries as a result of the disaster, though
the ecosystem of the lake was forever changed.
Further, three dogs died in the event.
Many lawsuits were filed, all settled out-of-court,
costing Texaco about $45 million, or about
$130 million today, in damages, with about
70% of that going to Diamond Crystal.
So thanks for watching this video, if you
liked it, please click that like button below
and consider sharing it with anyone you think
might be interested.
And of course if you’re new to TodayIFoundOut,
don’t forget to click the subscribe button
to get more interesting videos like this.
We release a new video almost every single
day, so you’re sure to find something you
find interesting.
Thanks for watching.